I'm Nick Shelton.
I'm one of the volunteers for the grasp Christian group at Google.
And what we've tried to do is have a monthly speaker series where our goal is to
say,
to bring in speakers who answered questions that Google can't answer.
Uh,
and so for this must stock,
we've invited Dr Josh.
Ash lasts to come and join us.
So I figured I would give a brief intro to him.
I'll let you know a little bit more about his work and then give it over to him
to offer the rest of the presentation.
So Dr Jeffress loss as a senior scholar at the Bio Logos Foundation and a
distinguished professor and TB Walker,
chair of biology at Westmont College,
which he also directs the Center for faith ethics in life sciences.
After his undergraduate studies in biology and philosophy on a solo programming
cramming four years of undergraduate study into eight,
I'll let him explain that one.
A Jeffery or received his PhD in ecology evolutionary biology from Washington
University and has since been a den for follow across from a fellow at the
University of Notre Dame.
A,
I'm a fellow at Saint Anne's college at Oxford and a weather spool fellow and
theology and science at the Princeton Center of theological inquiry.
Um,
his current research focuses on,
uh,
interactively influence human social cooperation and his own work.
Jeff is especially interested in helping the Christian and Soca secular public
appreciate the merchant findings,
a science and is fostering collegial commerce between scholars with differing
and no religious beliefs,
perfectly significant,
um,
and for ways of keeping his own sanity and closes on interest of surfing.
And so sophomore cutie mark.
Well that said,
I will give it over to Jeff to us.
Uh,
tell us more.
Okay,
that's great to be with you this afternoon.
I want to explore,
uh,
a conversation,
centuries old conversation that has sometimes been synergistically celebrative
and sometimes been acrimoniously polarizing a,
that's a conversation between science and religion.
And I want to begin by telling you a story and I hope it's okay to just give you
a little personal story here.
I'm holding my three and a half year old son,
Gabe and my arms one evening and we walk out the door to our house.
We live in Santa Barbara.
Um,
we don't get great sunsets in Santa Barbara,
often cause the maritime fog.
But this sunset was spectacular.
The Sky was hemispherically ablaze.
I've never really considered what it's like for a little kid to notice something
for the first time about the natural world that we see all the time.
But this was for the first time,
gave notice the sunset and I'm holding him in my arms in his head,
turns to me his lips were quivering and he says,
Daddy,
look,
God painted the sky.
Is it touching back kind of a painful moment.
Cause I had to say,
gave that stupid God had nothing to do with it.
That's just the differential elastic scattering of light.
No,
of course I did not say that.
Um,
but I tell you the story to kind of illustrate two points that we're going to
run with and this lecture.
And the first one was,
well,
was it stupid?
Um,
when we come up with a naturalistic explanation for things,
does that subvert the rational warrant for thinking that there's something
beyond nature?
Uh,
and the second one is well gave,
wasn't doing an analysis and the inference of,
to the best explanation,
he saw this and he just immediately intuitively
attributed it to God.
So that second question is where does these intuitions come from?
And over 300 years ago
not working,
uh,
the,
the Scottish philosopher David Hume says in his,
um,
natural history of religion is every inquiry which regards religion is of utmost
importance.
There are two questions in particular which challenge our attention to wit that
concerning its foundation in reason and that concerning its origin in human
nature.
Now for the last more than three centuries,
Ma,
most of the discussion has focused on that first one.
What implication?
So science have for rational warrant the foundations of religious belief in
reason.
But recently,
actually just within the last several decades,
there's been an explosion of research in to the second question.
What is it in human nature,
if anything that disposes this?
So those kinds of beliefs,
uh,
and there have been scarley and popular studies and genetics,
neuroscience,
cognitive science and evolutionary theory.
I want to concentrate on this ladder question with you.
What is it in human nature that seems disposed to these kinds of beliefs.
But in order to do that,
I need to set the context a and
the first question,
foundations and reasons.
So there's,
there's a popular perception that somehow the enterprises of scientific inquiry
and religious faith are intrinsically opposed.
Um,
a few years ago there was a theme issue in Time Magazine,
Richard Dawkins and Francis Collins,
both weight in Francis Collins,
the head of the human genome project,
and now the director of the National Institutes of health.
Um,
he actually founded by a logo.
So the organization with which I have an appointment,
um,
but it's not just popular controversy.
So here's one of dozens of quotes I can give you.
This one from John Dupre,
formerly up the road and the Department of Philosophy at Stanford,
uh,
Japan says Darwin undermines the only remotely plausible reason for believing in
the existence of God.
There's nothing worthwhile,
uh,
left of the argument from design and more controversially where contentiously I
want to insist that without the argument from design,
there's nothing very credible left of fee as in generally and Christianity in
particular.
Now I want to set aside the question of whether in fact the rational warrants
for faith rests on the argument from desire and turned that there are lots of
other arguments,
the argument from pers cause and the cosmological argument.
There are other reasons.
For example,
first person testimony or religious experience,
whether or not all of those are adequate is uh,
another question.
But it's,
it's not clear that faith ever rested entirely on the argument from design.
But more than that,
I want to look at this second comment that Darwin destroys the argument from
design and it turns out there's some merit to that,
but it's not that simple.
There is a tradition of two types of design attribution.
One type looks at the natural processes of the world and in a sense it reasons
when their deficiency says that natural processes are not able to account for
the observations that we make in nature.
And therefore there must be a supernatural intervener.
But there's another tradition all together that looks not at the deficiencies of
nature,
but the marvelous endowments of natural law.
So Newton was speaking in this tradition when he said the most beautiful system
of the sun planets and comets could only proceed when the council and dominion
of an intelligent being whom I call the Lord God.
Now,
that might be an argument,
not be an argument.
Actually it's an attribution,
but maybe that's kind of like Gabe and the sunset.
Maybe that was just the response and intuitive response by Newton since him.
However,
uh,
a number of arguments have been merged called pine tuning arguments.
I'm sure you've heard of them before,
but looking at fundamental constants of nature,
uh,
like the gravitational constant number of others,
which couldn't have differed by plus or minus more than a few percent in order
to have a licensed staining universe.
Paul Davies,
the physicists that Arizona State,
Arizona state calls it the goldilocks enigma.
One of my favorites is this one.
Uh,
it's not a continent of a natural law.
It's actually the initial conditions on which laws work,
the initial mass density of the universe.
So this is from a Ned,
right?
Ucla,
cosmologists and astrophysicists.
And he posits that the initial death mask,
NC,
the universe was fine tuned to one out of 10,
20 to the 24th,
or we're a septillion.
Actually,
he's revised this and added another digit,
um,
and one part greater.
And we would now be in the great collapse.
In other words,
we wouldn't be living.
And this notion of fine tuned to one out of 10 to the 24 is approximately
equivalent to plus or minus one scar.
Not In the night sky that we see you in our galaxy,
but in all the galaxies.
And he read scriptures that say,
lift up your eyes and look to the heavens who created all these.
He who brings out our story host one by one and calls forth each of them by name
because of his great power in mighty strength,
not one of them is missing.
And the psalmist says he determines the number of the stars and calls them each
by name.
Now I want to be really clear here.
I am not suggesting,
although some of my co-religionists do,
that this was a prophecy of what science would discover thousands of years
before the sciences were even invented.
Uh,
I'm not positing dad at all.
I am suggesting that what's here in the scriptural view of the world is that the
world is in fact a cosmos and not a Keto os to use a Greek notions that the
world and the cosmos we live in,
it in fact is structured and designed not designed because the laws require
supernatural intervention,
but decide because the laws themselves seem tuned to what would be necessary for
the rise of life.
And it's not just the scripture.
So a number of scientists have,
uh,
who have no faith in God by the way.
So Fred Hoyle was an atheist who said a common sense interpretation of the facts
suggest that a super intellect as monkeyed with physics as well as chemistry and
biology and up the road here,
a Leonard self scan at Stanford co-developer of string theory says our own
universe is an extraordinary place that appears to be fantastically well
designed for our own existence.
This specialness is not something that we can attribute to lucky accidents,
which is far too unlikely.
The apparent coincidence is cry out for an explanation.
Now here and each of the major points,
I want to make this this afternoon here,
I need to interject a but,
and it's a big,
but actually this quote that I just read you from Suskind is often taken out of
context.
Suskin does say that our universe is a special place,
but this quote is taken from his book,
the subtitle of which string theory and the illusion of intelligent design.
So he thinks our universe is a remarkably special place,
but our university isn't the only universe that there are many,
many,
many next door universes greatly amplifying the probability that we'd get a
universe that would support life.
There are various permutations of multiverse theory or mega verse theory.
And the point I want to make here,
the question doesn't settle.
So the book of Job Actually,
um,
I'm really moved by the fact that in the Hebrew scriptures,
the book of Joe Contains Friends of job who are giving arguments for God.
And at the end they get rebuked by God for defending him with quote unquote
proverbs of ashes.
So I didn't want to make that mistake.
These fine tuning arguments aren't slam dunks.
There's ongoing debate,
but it's also not the case that somehow Darwin settled the issue and subverted
all arguments from design.
One of my favorite thinkers,
Pascal.
But at this way,
he says,
there's enough light to see that there's something there worth seeing,
but not enough light to see it clearly by our natural reason.
He goes on to say,
if there were no obscurity,
man would not feed,
feel this need.
If there were no light,
man would not hope for a cure.
All appearance indicates neither a total exclusion or manifest presence of
divinity.
We must not see nothing at all nor math.
We see sufficient to believe that we possess it,
but we must see enough to know that we have lost it.
But to know of our loss,
we must see a Nazi.
And that's precisely the state in which we natural.
Lee are the picture here.
And I think this is the picture of the Christian faith,
is that you're not an idiot for believing in God.
It's a plausible hypothesis.
But what might persuade any of us that there is a god re requires reason is
necessary but not sufficient.
So this strange verse in the book of Romans,
Paul says,
his spirit testifies with our spirit that we are God's children.
There's something about the actual experience of the presence of God that's
important.
Um,
that may be delusional,
that I think I'd rather be delusional,
being dishonest.
I don't want to defend God with problems of ashes.
Okay,
so now we have this,
this question then,
where do these intuitions come from?
And here's the second part,
the origin in human nature.
There's a couple of ways of looking at this.
I'm biologist talk about proximate cause of an ultimate causes.
Proximate causes would be the mechanism that generates certain features,
including a mental dispositions and ultimate,
uh,
would be well of what adaptive value of if any is it.
So there's been a tremendous explosion in cognitive science of looking at
fundamental dispositions or intuitive,
uh,
dispositions towards certain kinds of beliefs that we might associate with God
or religious beliefs.
And by the way,
one of the really exciting things about this field is it's incredibly
ecumenical.
Uh,
it has Jews and Christians and Muslims and Jews who are practicing but don't
believe in God,
atheist,
virulent,
and nine,
uh,
we're all collaborating with each other.
It's up.
It's a fun moment right now of non acrimonious discussion.
So,
um,
just for example,
Justin Barrett
working,
uh,
Justin Barrett is a cognitive science.
This formerly,
uh,
Oxford,
APP,
the Institute for Cognition and culture.
And,
uh,
Jesse bearing is,
is a
sweet spirited but a very emphatic atheists.
Jesse says somewhat tongue in cheek,
but not all together.
We've got God by the throat and I won't stop until one of us is dead.
So he's wrestling with big issues.
Uh,
and here's some,
here's some work that Jesse did and so on.
Afterlife beliefs and children.
So he brings children in to the lab and he does a puppet show with an alligator
and a mouse.
And there's a story about the mouth.
Mouth wants to go home,
could be with his mother and he's feeling a little tired and he's hungry and
then the alligator eats the mouse.
Uh,
and then the children are sent off for grief counseling.
no,
that's not true.
That children are asked a series of questions about is there any continuity
between the mouse that was in the mouse that now is and they're told that mouse
is not alive anymore.
The alligator ate it.
So first of all,
a biological questions,
does the mouse still need to eat?
Still need to go to the bathroom cause the mouse's ears still work.
And the overwhelming majority of kids get that at death.
Your biological functions don't continue.
Although first,
uh,
although kindergarten,
it was about a quarter of them still say yes to these questions.
Second graders,
90% of them go.
Only one out of 10 says yes.
But then amp it up a little bit.
Psycho biological question.
Not does a mouse need to aid,
but does the mouse have the feeling of being hungry,
thirsty or sleepy?
Um,
this one,
uh,
two thirds of the kindergartener said yes and fully of the third,
and the second graders say yes,
and you have to get to fifth or sixth grade until you truncate continuity.
And about 90% of the sixth graders said No.
Now here's what's really interesting.
Lastly,
a different kind of questioned all together,
uh,
involving desires and feelings.
Does a mouse still want to go home?
Still loves his mom.
Mouse still believes that his mom is the nicest grownup,
the overwhelming majority of kindergarteners.
Ren
Fifth graders,
half of them say yes.
And what surprises me a little bit.
Um,
he brought in college students for this question and about a third of the
college students to the various items said yes.
Um,
and the ones that said no,
there is a latency.
Uh,
and their response when asked about the biological questions,
they said no.
Immediately when asked about the beliefs,
feelings,
and desires,
questions,
even the ones who said no,
uh,
there was a latency and they're answering.
So the psychologist at Yale,
Paul Bloom and editor of the Journal of Behavioral and Brain Sciences uses the
term natural born dualist,
um,
blue and believes that we're not taught these things.
If there's a natural disposition to think of life as enduring death,
maybe not all together in party.
Here's one other one.
How about purpose?
The attribution of purpose,
the things,
uh,
the inclination to think teleologically Deb Kellerman,
the psychologists have looked at this behavior in children and she asked
questions like,
why did the first bird exist?
Welcome Mike.
Nice music and be cleat because it makes the world look nice.
Why did the first monkey exists?
So then we had somebody to climb trees so there can be an animal in the jungle.
Why did the first monkey exist?
Oh,
I already did that.
Why did the first river exists?
So boats can come in the water and so that people can do fishing.
Telemann calls children intuitive fist.
But the interesting thing is she's followed up on these studies with adults,
uh,
including by the way doctorally trained academics,
a number in the natural sciences.
Uh,
and there's still this late and disposition to think teleologically uh,
and adults.
Now what there isn't there.
These,
these features May,
I guess,
embodied being is in Jesse's work,
intuitive theosis or,
uh,
purpose orientation and kill him his work.
These attributes are attributes of God.
Um,
but when she calls children intuitive theist,
the one thing that is lacking there that exists in most concepts in the current,
uh,
world monotheism is a sacred dimension.
So these concepts could be true of leprechauns for that,
but there's something about a sacred dimension and that's,
that's something that hasn't been much studied in the current cognitive science
of religion.
Nevertheless,
it's really true that we,
we have this disposition to think in terms of purpose.
Richard Dawkins himself says,
we humans have purpose on the brain.
The mere fact that it's possible to frame a question doesn't make it legitimate
or sensible to do so.
You have no right to assume the why question deserves an answer when posed about
a boulder misfortune now in avarice or the universe.
Now it's interesting here,
um,
Dawkins says and give a reason why no one has a right to ask that question.
Uh,
he takes it as a given and in fact,
this seems to emerge out of a fundamental and profound intuition on his part
that there is no purpose.
So in one sense,
we have a battling intuitions here.
Uh,
although it might seem to you like we'll surely we can't think of in terms of a
purpose of a mountain,
but as we grow older,
it may be the case that we are more parsimonious in what we attribute purchase a
purpose too,
but also more expansive and elevating in terms of how we construe purpose.
So if you want to think in terms of the purpose of a mountain,
for example,
this isn't a religious statement,
but I'd highly recommend reading John Muir's,
uh,
the mountains of California or his,
my first summer in the Sierra.
There's a reverential elevation of these entities,
uh,
not just in an in an aesthetic sense,
but in some sense,
uh,
in terms of the larger teleology,
okay,
whatever in the case,
the cognitive sciences suggest that we have an eight distribute disposition to
attribute and not just to attribute,
but to yearn for purpose.
Augustine says,
you have made us for yourself and the heart is restless until it finds its rest
in you.
Now,
the first question is a theological statement you have made us for yourself.
The second question is a psychological statement that our heart is hearts are
restless.
Uh,
and so why,
uh,
why would that be the case?
And now I'm going to take a step back and ask the evolutionary question.
Why would creatures have these dispositions?
And there again,
there's an explosion of evolutionary literature on cognitive dispositions toward
religious belief.
There's been a fascinating debate,
by the way.
So some argue that we don't have those dispositions,
that religion is a cultural pathogen that infects our brains.
Richard Dawkins says,
religion is a virus more deadly than the smallpox virus.
Bit more difficult to
a other say.
We'll know given the empirical work,
um,
there may be cultural constructs,
but our brain is very receptive to these.
And in fact our brain is disposed to construct these cultural notions.
But it's not adaptive.
It's a byproduct.
It's an incidental byproduct of other cognitive mechanisms that do have adaptive
function.
And of course,
a third position in this debate is,
no,
it may be a byproduct,
but human culture has,
has learned how to use these dispositions for the flourishing of culture.
Now I want to focus on this last perspective,
um,
in part because it's one that I've been working on for the last decade,
but I actually think it's would be accurate to say that there's emerging
consensus,
uh,
and the cognitive and anthropological evolutionary sciences of,
of religion.
So here we go.
Ah,
I'll set the context with something that virtually everyone agrees on.
So here's an article from the philosophical transactions of the Royal Society.
Human cooperation exceeds that of all other species with regard to the scale and
range of activities.
Human beings cooperate with individuals that are not genetic,
genetically related and that are outside,
uh,
the group boundaries of face to face historically,
remembered interactions.
And we're the only creatures that do that systematically 40 years ago now.
And as seminal sociobiology Eo Wilson says,
man has achieved an extraordinary degree of cooperation exactly how he alone has
been able to cross to this.
Pinnacle is the culminating mystery of all biology.
Well,
that was 40 years ago.
Uh,
and we have,
this would be a talking in and of itself,
but we've come up with,
uh,
numerous fascinating and really plausible explanations for this,
but I'm going to concentrate on one.
We'll start with this.
It's obvious that in human cultures,
um,
and actually another socially organisms of punishment is important.
So one of the,
one of the aspects of human cooperation that is so difficult to sustain because
it's so open to defection is not me cooperating with nick.
If I burn him,
he won't work with me.
But they happen.
It involves common goods,
uh,
where large,
members of a large community invest in and take from a pool of shared resources.
And the community can become so large that you get pre riders,
you get people who don't make their investment or you get people who take more,
uh,
than is their share.
A Garrett Hardin called this the tragedy of the Commons.
But punishment can constrain this.
So here's a common goods game running the lab where people are given certain
monetary endowment,
you put it in the pool,
it triples,
and then you divided equally amongst everybody in the game,
including by the white people who didn't contribute anything.
And as you can see,
people figure out over time that I'm getting burned by these effectors and an,
and then investment in the common pool goes down but admit punishment,
uh,
and it goes up.
So punishment is really effective in stabilizing cooperation.
But there's some limitations to this idea.
First of all,
punishment costs and the particular game you had to pay to punish,
but in societies punished kind of punishment costs.
If you confront somebody,
they might poke you in the nose.
We have to pay for policemen.
It's not free.
And secondly,
punishment is only as good as the detection is of defectors.
So it's limited by the accuracy of the detection.
And then lastly,
punishers are bribed bubble.
They had their own self interests.
So what we'd want ideally to stabilize cooperation in a society is a,
a moral overseer who's free,
who's omniscient and his unbreakable.
Well,
you see where this is going.
Um,
that's the positive role of believing in supernatural punishment.
So,
um,
the notions here are the rise of moralizing deities,
which by the way is dip,
not all religions.
So in some religions,
um,
proposed the cities that are either not interested in the affairs of humans or
are not viewed as a moral beings themselves.
The rise of moral deity seems to correspond with the extension of the size of
human interaction,
div units and culture with the rise of agriculture.
Um,
but this is certainly not an,
and what novel proposal,
I mean,
Voltaire,
centuries ago said,
if God did not exist,
it would be necessary to invent him.
Now,
some people take this as kind of a sarcastic repudiation of God that he was
invented,
but that's not what Volterra Matt.
Now he was at from a critic of a number of aspects of the Christian tradition,
but he went on to say,
but all nature cries out that he does exist,
that there is a supreme intelligence and immense power and admirable order and
everything teaches us our dependence on it
for a reason of social coherence.
Now,
in the last few years,
um,
there's just been in a rupture of empirical literature testing this hypothesis
and a couple of books,
by the way,
fun books are northern Zions big gods,
how religion transform cooperation and conflict.
And Don Johnson's God is watching you how the fear of God makes us human.
Um,
dom has a dual phd
political science and evolutionary biology.
His appointment is at Oxford.
Uh,
and both these guys are wonderful colleagues.
both are atheists.
They have absolutely no religious bro religious agenda,
uh,
but they're persuaded that religious belief,
particularly belief in moralizing gods has been,
uh,
has played a really crucial role in the origin of human culture.
And in fact,
there's some empirical data,
I'll just share a couple with you.
This is from some work that our ed,
yet he brought people in and they played the dictator game where you get certain
amount of money and he'd share as little or as much with uh,
an anonymous partner.
And as they were doing that,
he gave them subliminal primes on the computer.
And when prime with a religious concept like spirit or God or Bible,
uh,
the offers,
basically doubled.
Now he also used secular police type crimes and it had the same effect.
So no one's saying here that necessarily that religion,
uh,
produces a greater effect.
It's just that there may be other benefits as a backup mechanism is a mechanism
that doesn't have to be paid for.
But does this,
this is in the lab,
is there any data to suggest that actually exerts cultural or social influence?
Okay.
And my colleague Rich Sosus,
a evolutionary anthropologists that University of Connecticut,
uh,
looked at historical records per 200 religious and secular communes in 19th
century America.
And he found that for every year of their life course,
religious communes were about four times as likely to survive.
So just the survival of communes is tremendously,
uh,
influence by community,
religious identity or lack thereof.
Uh,
and there's rich.
Yeah.
Now there's limitations here.
And the limitations here are,
I mean,
uh,
here's a Gary Larson cartoon,
but this idea of a punishing,
vengeful God actually may be efficacious and constraining defection,
but what it doesn't seem to be able to do is motivates super auditory.
There's a word from a philosophical ethics motivate behavior that goes above and
beyond the minimal expectations.
So God might this,
God might punish you for doing wrong for violating what you're obligated to do.
But we see people all the time doing what they're not obligated to do.
So you might think of something dramatic like a,
you know,
living a life of poverty and celibacy on behalf of serving the poor.
But it could also be something just as simple as pulling over in a snow storm,
uh,
to help a stranger on the side of the road.
He's going to have a gas.
Um,
so one problem is this doesn't explain superogatory behavior.
Uh,
and another problem he has any society that relies exclusively on belief in God
to do.
It's more a policing ma is vulnerable to infection by people who don't share
that belief.
So here's the next uh,
and current installment.
It's called costly signaling is,
uh,
a long history of biological thing,
thinking about signaling and nonhuman species.
But the idea here is that one of the ways that a community can assure itself
that interacting members in fact do share these beliefs is by commitment
singling mechanisms,
costly behaviors.
Like for example,
I'm taking one day off every seven and not and not working or giving 10% of your
income of voluntarily or not eating a whole range of food which would otherwise
be available.
Richard's gone back and he's actually gone back to his commune study and looked
at the number of costly costly behaviors and found that conduit commun longevity
increased with an increasing number of costly behaviors.
But by the way,
only for religious,
uh,
comments,
had no effect on secular continents.
Well,
that's part of the story.
But there are limitations of this too.
And the limitations are number one,
for a costly signal,
whether it's a peacock's tail or a religious practice,
for it to be sustainable,
although it costs,
it has to be compensated for by the benefit to the,
to the signaler.
If it weren't,
it wouldn't be sustainable.
But now if the cost is compensated for it by the benefit,
then people who don't believe we'd be willing to pay the costs because they get
more out of it.
Uh,
we see this by the way,
and a lower level in American politics.
It's almost impossible to get elected to major political office if you're not a
church goer.
And
I will forego a comment about our current political situation in the u s um,
but that's one problem.
The other problem is this,
the costly signaling hypothesis doesn't,
uh,
engage what does a prominent teaching in many religious traditions,
which is that what you do,
you shouldn't do publicly.
So in the Christian tradition,
for example,
Jesus says,
when you give,
don't give publicly as the hypocrites do,
blasting a trumpet before then,
but given secret back,
don't even let your left hand know what your right hand is doing.
And when you pray,
don't pray publicly as the hypocrites do,
but pray in secret in your closet.
And your father who sees in secret will reward you and secret.
So there's this stream of religious exhortation and back to not do exactly these
public displays of religiosity.
And that brings up the last and final issue.
Yeah,
it's an issue I have to say that is under investigated right now.
But it's the issue of religious experience
in order to motivate us toward superogatory behaviors.
Those that were not absolutely motivate,
uh,
obligated to do or in order to draw us into religious practices that don't
enhance our reputation.
It might be the case that whether it's delusional or not,
a person who believes that they experienced the presence and intimacy and love
of God,
uh,
Mike do these things.
So in the,
in the New Testament,
Paul says,
we comfort others with the comfort we ourselves receive from God.
The last few years,
uh,
my lab has been looking at the relationship between religious experience and
measures of pro sociality,
uh,
trust and generosity.
I've been doing this,
uh,
with Hilary Lindh festy now at the school of human evolution and social change
at Arizona State.
And Paul Zak from the center for new or newer economic studies that at Claremont
Graduate University.
And we have,
we have folks come into the lab,
take a series of inventory just where they self report on their sense of
gratitude,
toward God's sense of intimacy with God,
belief that they're loved by God.
Um,
then we have them actually do a variety of activities,
sometimes playing the game or singing folk songs or worshiping together.
Um,
we take,
we monitored their oxytocin,
which is a hormone that we know mediate social relationship.
Uh,
and then we have them play a variety of economic transfer experiments,
standard experiments in behavioral economics.
And,
um,
here's what we found.
We found that generosity,
um,
scales to a sense of divine gratitude.
And animacy.
We found that in the activities,
uh,
it is enhanced,
by worship in particular,
highly experiential,
uh,
or emotional modes of worship.
And we have worked with Pentecostal people from the Pentecostal tradition and,
and worked in it ugly.
Um,
we found that generosity scales before and after oxytocin,
a plasma oxytocin levels,
although we're still analyzing that data.
Interestingly,
um,
in most of these runs,
there've been no ingroup outgroup difference.
So one of the prevailing theories of,
um,
of the social valley religion is it tremendously increases in group commitment
at the expense of outgroup hostility.
Uh,
we haven't found that,
uh,
and a number of recent studies actually have taken a deeper look at this ingroup
outgroup.
It turns that that there's a big,
large amount of research that associates religious commitment with racial
prejudice,
but,
uh,
and strong outgroup boundaries.
When we take a deeper look,
if we divide up the religious commitment into what's called extrinsic and
intrinsic religiosity,
extrinsic,
uh,
involves kind of conformity to external rules,
oftentimes for the conscious consciously for the sake of a personal benefit.
Intrinsic is an internalized experience and commit commitment to religious
principles.
Uh,
it turns out that intrinsic religiosity,
uh,
is associated with a permeability and relaxation of group areas and intrinsic
religiosity is associated with the rigid effication of group barriers.
Okay.
So
one last snapshot.
If in fact,
we are disposed to have certain kinds of beliefs and if in fact those beliefs
and the practices associated with them,
uh,
relate to,
the establishment of social coherence,
is there anything inside us that would benefit and welcome from and welcome
those pleats?
So,
last couple of decades,
there have been an explosion of literature on religion and health.
This would be a talking to and of itself,
but I want to give you a snapshot and I'll close with a suggestion for an
interesting review if any of you are interested in it.
But there have been over 3000 studies,
the overwhelming majority of which have associated,
uh,
re various measures of religious involvement,
with cardiac and cancer and all cause mortality,
a reduction measures of life satisfaction,
various majors of mental health,
depression,
PTSD,
even suicide.
And I told j h and my points would have a butt and there's a big,
but here,
uh,
the body has many,
if not most of these studies while the correlations are there were weekly
designed because they were cross sectional rather than Longitudinal.
They particular groups,
uh,
and scale them in terms of their religiosity but they didn't follow them.
And the problem with that is this,
if you have a correlation between church attendance and mental health or
physical health,
we don't know whether church attendance and the involvement and community and
the meaning making,
uh,
improves physical or mental health.
Or is it just the case that people with mental or physical ailments are less
likely to get out?
So a lot of these studies have been flawed,
but in the last couple of years there've been some really,
really interesting,
well done longitudinal studies.
I'll just show you one,
uh,
from the American Medical Association Journal of Internal Medicine.
Um,
this study was,
it took 75,000 nurses and follow them over 20 years.
They adjusted for age,
alcohol,
smoking,
educational level of the individual and their spouse.
If they had one exercise,
diet,
vitamins,
hypertension,
body mass index,
depression,
family income,
and even measures of social integration adjusted for this at the beginning of
the study.
And then just monitored church attendance,
uh,
on a questionnaire submitted every four years.
And it turns out that there was in those who retain,
attended church once or more a week,
there's a 33% reduction in all cause mortality a over this 20 year period.
Now,
why would this be the case?
Um,
we can take a look at that and the question section if anybody wants to discuss
that.
But since this study,
there have been a tremendous,
uh,
a great number of other,
can comment variable control,
longterm longitudinal studies that have found similar outcomes for various
measures of physical and psychological health.
And I'll just mentioned that there's a really wonderful review of this work,
uh,
a few months ago and the proceedings of the National Academy of Sciences,
one of the most prestigious scientific journals there is.
This work was done by Tyler Vanderwiel,
who's has joint appointments in the Department of Epidemiology and
biostatistics,
uh,
at the Harvard School of Public Health.
Tyler has been very critical of a lot of the previous studies,
but in this review paper,
he looked only at Longitudinal studies,
uh,
that can controlled for concomitant variables.
And the reason I'm recommending it to you is because it's not just on religion
and health.
Uh,
it's on the promotion of human flourishing.
So he looks at various out majors of human flourishing,
which includes statements of emotional happiness,
of stability,
of personal relationships,
uh,
physical health and some sense of meaning in one's life.
And he reviews literature in four areas,
family structure,
education work,
and religious involvement and finds that all of these things make substantial
causal contributions to human flourishing.
So to close,
none of this makes religion true.
In fact,
it doesn't even make religion uniformly beneficial.
There are negative God's beliefs that have demonstrably toxic effects on
individual and social flourishing.
But what this does represent is the questions represent fascinating areas of
open minded,
scientific inquiry.
Some of these people I mentioned Don Johnson and enrich SOSUS.
Um,
I've had the privilege of collaborating with for many years.
Dom's an atheist.
A rich is a practicing Jew,
a though I don't know whether he's a ps.
Uh,
I'm a Christian.
We have a fantastic fun with each other and it's a fascinating area of study in
which I think it represents right now.
Not Conclusions looking for evidence,
uh,
but answers,
really looking questions,
really looking for answers.
But in addition to being an area that's fun for openminded scientific inquiry,
I think it's one worthy of existential inquiry as well.
So I'll quote close with a quote from Pascal who I began with.
The God of Christians is not a god who is simply the author of the mathematical
truth or that ruler of the elements.
He's not merely a god who exercises his providence over the life and fortunes of
men.
The got a Christians is a god of love and of comfort,
a god who fills the soul and the heart of those.
He possesses a god who makes them conscious of their inward waywardness and his
infinite mercy
who unites himself to their inmost soul and who fills it with humility and joy
with confidence and love,
who renders them incapable of any other end than himself.
Thank you very much.
Yeah,
thank you for that.
You condensed a lot into 45 minutes and luckily it does give us 15 minutes for
questions and we can go a little bit overboard.
Uh,
so I will,
um,
you know,
pass around the mic.
A case one has here and we do have a dory online.
I'll actually rotate between questions on that.
And any of you live streaming,
if you do want to ask a question our door,
is it go f a f Dory
first.
Does anyone have opening question from the room?
Have not actually had a question myself.
Um,
so I'm a,
I remember getting reference of s,
uh,
kind of a study that kind of went along against the idea of faith and
flourishing.
Uh,
was I believe a did mark study that was talking about how people that were there
and I guess it goes back to the flourishing part or being more happy and all
that.
And I like how people outside of the realms of religion and of that are lead it
out.
So do you have any,
yeah,
that's,
I'm glad you're asking it.
And I told you from the start,
I'm,
these are complicated issues.
I'm nervous about oversimplifying.
Um,
but let's take a look at that.
Okay.
So here,
this is,
uh,
an international survey.
The percentage saying that religion is important in their daily life versus
what's the quality of your life today.
One is from Matt.
It shouldn't be one that you'd be 10 very bath one is the worst possible and
Denmark is at the top and it's one of the least religious,
uh,
cultures on the planet.
Togo is way down at the bottom and it's highly religious.
By the way,
this isn't just true internationally.
So if we look at,
um,
emotional wellbeing is a Gallup poll with no particular ax to grind and
religious attention,
attendance by state,
um,
there's a negative relationship
and it's also true with life expectancy,
uh,
a negative relationship.
So here's my comment.
First of all,
these studies actually suffer from the same weakness that I said other
correlational studies suffer from.
They're not controlling for concomitant variables.
So it may in fact be the case that,
um,
from,
for various reasons,
uh,
as the default standard of living as a society rises,
the religiosity goes down.
Um,
but so does health or happened,
but health and happiness goes up,
we'd call that concomitant variability.
The other possible problem with these studies is that they represent what's been
called the ecological fallacy.
Ecological fallacies is sampling at the wrong scale.
So,
and by the way,
my own initial training within ecology actually in the size of the sampling
unit,
it made all the difference in what we'd find in terms of correlation within
environmental variable.
So,
and I want to thank,
um,
the social psychiatry at colleges,
David Myers for this,
if we look at a different scale,
if we look at the individual scale here in the u s we get the exact opposite.
Uh,
we have increasing happiness with number,
just church attendance,
and we get the same relationship,
uh,
with life expectancy if we look at the individual scale.
So with respect to those studies,
I don't want to dismiss them too cavalierly,
uh,
but they're not longitudinal.
Um,
and they don't control for concomitant variables.
Uh,
and they may suffer from the ecological fallacy.
When I do have a question that came in at the Doreen and,
uh,
this is from grace from Sydney,
Australia,
she said,
it's awesome to hear how the ways that science and faith intersect,
but I also wanted to hear how people argue that humans just think they need
religion.
We can know whether,
how can we know that we are wired for the evidence of God's intelligent design
or his religion or a result of how we are wired?
Yeah.
Well,
that's the big question.
So,
uh,
we,
we might sub divided into two questions.
The first one's an empirical question.
Does it look like humans?
By the way?
I wouldn't say wired because wired suggested it's in our hardware.
Um,
and that,
um,
and somehow it's absolutely a Nate and that no matter what context we grew up
in,
uh,
we have these dispositions.
I don't think that's the case.
I'm biologist described peanut types as gene by environment interactions.
So one is the empirical question of are we disposed to believe certain things,
uh,
growing up in environments that are typical human family and cultural
environments that are typical of the natural history of our species.
Uh,
and I would say we are,
we are disposed to do those things.
And then the next question,
uh,
okay.
As,
as we,
um,
as we construct them in imbibe,
those kinds of beliefs are,
we not only dispose to hold them,
but did they make a positive difference in our life?
I'd say here,
um,
the data are complicated,
depends on the nature of the beliefs and the way we embrace them.
Uh,
but today the same,
pretty robust,
uh,
that certain kinds of beliefs and behaviors held in certain ways are contributed
to flourishing at both individual and social levels.
Now,
uh,
our friend in Australia question is,
okay,
so,
uh,
do we have the beliefs cause we're wired,
to generate them.
Um,
or do we have them because there is a creator who wired us to have them.
Well that's not a question that's empirically answerable has it.
Um,
what we can say is,
um,
contrary to it in a number of the folks I cited here is it doesn't look like
from the empirical data.
There's anything that would subvert that belief.
But the design argument itself,
whether it's fine tuning of the cosmos or whether it's fine tuning of the human
cognitive architecture,
I'm going to go back to Pascal on this.
There was enough light to see that there's something there we're seeing and not
enough light to see it clearly.
And Pascal says that that's actually a good thing because if we came to belief
in God by purely rational inference a,
we'd believe in God as a proposition.
And he says,
if we have this hunch,
this question that there might be a god and we come to God and ask him,
are you there and have an interaction with him,
uh,
then we have a god who's the relational loving being.
Thanks.
Thanks for the talk.
Um,
so I have a question regarding these studies and a little bit,
I think you've kind of alluded to it.
Um,
just the confounding factors of it.
So you mentioned that yes,
their career section on some longitudinal right with 20 years is a long time and
uh,
you know,
you normalizing the beginning,
but if you keep going to church,
perhaps you'll find a group of people that you enjoy being with and the husband
and we know those factors actually are affecting your level of happiness.
So how do you,
how can you explain that?
Not so much genetics,
but like also like the effect of the environment and how that interacts with
religion.
So,
um,
this was a 20 year study.
I mean,
I,
I'm a little overwhelmed at the,
at the scale this study cause the 75,000 people over 20 years and they actually
went back every four years and checked with them and adjusted for covariates.
Uh,
so that graph I showed you at the end was a graph at not of the actual mortality
data,
but a model of the mortality data once these other,
uh,
covariates had been adjusted for.
So it's,
um,
we need more studies like that.
But now that the next question would be,
well,
why,
what's going on here?
And it's,
they did what's called mediating analysis and it looks like that even after
controlling for covariance,
uh,
it looks like social inclusion,
um,
was an important factor and optimism and hope,
uh,
was an important factor and that different between the two groups longitudinally
study.
Now,
one question we might ask is,
okay,
well if we had something other than religion that would contribute to folks
sense of social inclusion,
uh,
in buoyancy or optimism,
could that perform a similar function?
And maybe so maybe,
maybe they should look in Denmark,
maybe like a place like Denmark where people are,
I mean,
I'm just,
I'm not saying just being a little bit,
but then mark would be a place where people maybe have that hope because
socially the situation is not as dire.
So if you go to Togo,
like there's not much there.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean there's stuff,
but you know what I mean?
Yeah,
for sure.
Yup.
Sometimes is the feeling of belonging to a group can mediate that effect too.
Yeah.
So,
um,
yeah,
we do need more international studies of the things.
Uh,
here in the u s uh,
there have been a number of studies that have targeted different cultural groups
as well.
So a number of studies have looked at just the effects.
One study looked at just effects a religious involvement on coronary heart
disease in African Americans,
for example.
So different social group with the different,
different social challenges.
Okay.
We did have one more question in the door and uh,
and it was actually about,
um,
just like definitions of flourishing is,
I think this was in reference back to your slide.
I'm talking about the oxytocin and measuring yet.
So I think what they were trying to ask is,
uh,
what is your definition of flourishing personally?
And is there a definition that science can give us of what is exactly who my
people are seeing and where would be the intersection of the two?
Well,
I'll start with the first one.
I,
I'd be really nervous if we relied on science that tells us what human
flourishing is.
The sciences do two things,
not there.
Uh,
they attempt to rigorously describe regularities and the natural world and then
they attempt to generate causal explanations for those regularities.
Um,
so,
you know,
risk at Tealium terms,
science proposed as efficient causes of things.
Aristotle also talked about final causes.
He talked about,
uh,
the ends for which things are constructed and his notion of nature,
for example,
of,
of human nature or the nature of anything was highly teleological,
uh,
that we had a particular end.
And,
and his view.
Um,
and in the view probably of most of us here,
if there's isn't end,
uh,
let's see if there is a normative t lows and we miss it.
Well that's called,
that's called tragedy or in in physical context is called illness.
Um,
but science camp decide what that end is,
nor Contra Dawkins candidate decide whether there is such an hand.
So my definition of flourishing,
uh,
in my own life,
um,
well even before I was a Christian,
I thought that ultimately flourishing
was to have a matrix of intimate and loving relationships with other folks with
whom I could be myself.
Uh,
they could be their selves to me and for home,
we would be invested in one another.
But,
uh,
in speaking autobiographically that Anna and I am so grateful I've had that in
my life,
but that wasn't enough and I actually construe ultimate flourishing and the
Augustinian terms you have made us for yourself.
And the heart is restless until it finds its recipe,
knew that flourishing,
uh,
if loving embrace of,
and by our creator who made us specifically for that end.
Wow.
Thank you for that.
Great to be with you.
Enjoy,
man.
A round of applause.
[inaudible].